so let's start thinking about partial
derivatives of vector fields so a vector
field is a function I'll do I'll just do
a two-dimensional example here there's
going to be something that has a
two-dimensional input and then the
output has the same number of dimensions
that's the important part and each of
these components in the output is going
to depend somehow on the input variables
so the example have in mind will be x
times y is that first component and then
y squared minus x squared as that second
component and you can compute the
partial derivative of a guy like this
right you'll take the partial derivative
with respect to one of the input
variables I'll choose X it's always a
nice one to start with partial
derivative with respect to X and if we
were to actually compute it in this case
it's another function of x and y what
you do is you take the partial
derivative component-wise so you go to
each component and the first one you say
okay X looks like a variable Y looks
like a constant the derivative will just
be that constant and then the partial
derivative of this second component that
Y squared looks like a constant
derivative of negative x squared with
respect to X negative 2x so analytically
if you know how to take a partial
derivative you already know how to take
a partial derivative of vector valued
functions and hence vector fields but
the fun part that the important part
here how do you actually interpret this
and this has everything to do with
visualizing it in some way so the the
vector field the reason we call it a
vector field is you kind of take the
whole XY plane and you're gonna fill it
with vectors and concretely what I mean
by that you'll take a given input what's
an input you want to look at like um
I'll say maybe 1 2 or yeah let's do that
let's do 1 2 now which would mean you
kind of go x equals 1 and then y equals
2 this input point and we want to
associate that with the output vector in
some way and so let's just compute what
it should equal so when we plug in x
equals 1 and y equals 2x times y becomes
2 y squared minus x squared becomes 2
squared minus 1 squared so 4 minus 1 is
3 so we have this vector 2 3 that we
want to associate with that input point
and vector fields you just attach the
two points you just I'm going to take
the vector 2
three and attach it to this guy so we
should have an X component of two and
then a Y component of three so it's
going to end up looking something like
let's see so a lot of component of three
something like this so that'll be the
vector and we attach it to that point
and in principle you do this to all of
the different points and if you did what
you'd get would be something like this
and remember when we represent these
especially with computers it tends to
lie where each represented vector is
much much shorter than it should be in
reality but you just want to squish them
all on to the same page so they don't
overrun each other and here color is
supposed to give a general vague sense
of relative length so ones that are blue
should be thought of as much shorter
than the ones that are yellow but that
doesn't really give like a specific
thought for how long they should be but
for partial derivatives we actually care
a lot about the specifics and if you
think if you think back to how we
interpret partial derivatives in a lot
of other contexts what we want to do is
imagine this partial X here as a slight
nudge in the X Direction right so this
this was our original input and you
might imagine just nudging it a little
bit and the size of that nudge as a
number would be your partial X so then
the question is what's the resulting
change to the output and because the
output is a vector the change in the
output is also going to be a vector it's
what we want is to say there's gonna be
some other vector attached to this point
right it's gonna look very similar maybe
it looks like maybe it looks something
like this so something similar but maybe
a little bit different and you you want
to take that that difference in vector
form and I'll describe what I mean by
that in just a moment and then divide it
by the size of that original nudg so to
be to be much more specific about what I
mean here if you're comparing two
different vectors and they're rooted in
two different spots I think a good way
to start is to just move them to a new
space where they're rooted in the same
spot so in this case I'm just gonna kind
of draw a separate space over here and
be thinking of this as a place for these
vectors to live and I'm gonna I'm gonna
put them both on this plane but I'm
gonna route them each in the origin so
this first one that has components 2 3
let's give it a name right let's call
this guy v1 ok so that'll be V 1 and
then the nudged output the the second
one I'll call v2
vitu and let's say v2 is also in the
space and I might exaggerate the
difference just so that we can see it
here let's say let's say it was
different in some way but in reality if
it's a small nudge it'll be different in
only a very small way now but let's say
let's say these were our two vectors the
difference the difference between these
guys is going to be a vector that
connects the tips and I'm going to call
that guy like partial V and the way that
you can be thinking about this is to say
that V 1 V 1 that original guy Plus that
that tiny nudge the difference between
them is equal to V 2
you know the nudged output and in terms
of tip to tail with vectors either
you're saying that kind of the green
vector plus that blue vector is the same
as that that pink vector that connects
the the tail of the original one to the
tip of the new one so when we're
thinking of a partial derivative you're
basically saying hey what happens if we
take this the nudge the size of the
nudge of the output and then we divide
it by that nudge of the input so let's
say you were thinking of that original
not just being I don't know like of a
size 1/2 like 0.5 as the the change in
the X Direction then that would mean
when you go over here and you say what's
that DV that changed changing vector V
divided by DX you'd be dividing it by
0.5 and in principle you'd be thinking
of that would mean that you're kind of
scaling this by 2 as if to say this
little DV is 1/2 of of some other vector
and that other vector is what the
partial derivative is so this other
vector here the full blue guy would be
DV you know scaled down or scaled up
however you want to think about it by
that partial X and that's what makes it
such that you know in principle if this
partial X change was really small was
like 1/100 and the output and I'd also
was really small as like 1/100 or you
know something on that order it wouldn't
be specifically that then the DV DX that
change would still be a normal sized
vector and the direction that it points
is still kind of an indication of the
direction that this green vector should
change as you're as you're scooting over
so just to be concrete and you know
actually compute this guy let's say we
were to take this partial derivative
partial of V with respect to X
and evaluate it at that point one two
that we're just dealing with one two
what that would mean Y is equal to two
so that first component is 2 and then X
is equal to 1 so that next one should be
negative 2 and we can I guess we can see
just how wrong my drawing was to start
here I was just kind of guessing what
the pink vector would be but I guess it
changes in the direction of 2 negative 2
so that should be something you're all
erase the what turns out to be the wrong
direction here yeah but to do get rid of
this guy and I guess the change should
be in the direction kind of 2 as the X
component and then negative 2 that's a
negative 2 as the Y component so the
derivative vector should look something
like this which means all corresponding
little DV nudges will be slight changes
will be slight changes on that so these
will be your your DV is something in
that direction and what that means in
our vector field then as you move in the
X direction and consider the various
vectors attached to each point as you
kind of passing through the point 1 2
the way that the vectors are changing
should somebody somehow you know down
into the right the tip should move down
into the right so if this starts you
know highly up and to the right then it
should be getting kind of shorter but
then longer to the right so the v2 if I
were to have drawn it more accurately
here you know what that nudged output
should look like it would really be
something that's kind of like I don't
know like this where it's getting
shorter in the Y direction but then
longer in the X direction as per that
blue nudging arrow and in the next video
I'll kind of go go through more examples
of how you might think of this how do
you think of it in terms of what each
component means which becomes very
important for later topics like
divergence and curl and I'll see you
next video